salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore une
chaîne pour apprendre créés et partagés
alors aujourd'hui on est parti faire une
petite session en photo rien que pour
vous et tout ça pour vous expliquer
comment on peut obtenir sur des photos
ou des vidéos un fond flou bien crémeux
bien joli bien stylé et surtout comment
réussir à l'obtenir à tous les coups
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
alors vous avez sûrement déjà pu
observer cette technique sur des photos
ou des vidéos on a un sujet qui est très
nette et un arrière-plan qui est flou et
c'est un effet vraiment vraiment sympa
comme ici d'ailleurs alors ça se fait
beaucoup pour les portraits mais c'est
une technique qui n'a de limite que
celle de votre imagination
donc c'est toujours intéressant de
savoir comment l'appliquer et ça qu'on
ait un réflexe un smartphone un compact
avec n'importe quel appareil
c'est théoriquement possible sauf que
vous bat quand vous essayez il n'y a
peut-être pas de flou alors pas de
panique on va voir comment l'obtenir
quasiment à tous les coups et ça quel
que soit votre appareil mais bon pour y
arriver il faut que je vous explique
deux trois trucs avant alors tout
d'abord à quoi est dû ce fameux flou où
il fait beau quai et bien c'est lié à ce
qu'on appelle la profondeur de champ
alors pour faire simple la profondeur de
champ c'est la zone qui va être nette
sur votre photo ou votre vidéo par
exemple là je suis net
mais là je suis fou et et là aussi shui
flou il est floue ce mec il est floue
jeu de mots pourri je vous faire un
petit schéma pour vous expliquer il faut
visualiser le champ de vision comme un
triangle là c'est vous et là c'est
l'arrière-plan question optique dans
cette vidéo par exemple on a un truc
comme ça
la zone bleue c'est la zone est devant
c'est flou et derrière c'est flou aussi
la profondeur de champ elle est liée en
partie à l'ouverture du diaphragme de
l'objectif de l'appareil photo
c'est un élément de l'objectif qui va
laisser entrer plus ou moins de lumière
selon sa taille et ses réglages
d'ailleurs sur un reflex l'ouverture est
souvent variable pour résumer plus
l'ouverture est grande plus il ya de
lumière qui va rentrer dans l'objectif
plus le flou d'arrière plan va être
important autrement dit plus le chiffre
de l'ouverture est petit plus la
profondeur de champ est réduite et donc
plus il ya de flou par exemple ici j'ai
ouvert à 2,8 ce qui est l'ouverture
maximale de mon objectif
la profondeur de champ est réduite et
c'est pour ça que je suis net et que le
fond est floue mais ici j'ai ouvert à 11
may profondeur de champ et donc plus
étendue je suis net et le fond aussi il
faudra aussi garder en tête que pour
avoir un fond flou il faut que se font
justement soit suffisamment éloigné du
sujet pour ne pas se trouver dans la
zone de netteté
genre si tu fais à un portrait de
quelqu'un dos à un mur il est juste à
côté ça va être compliqué de ne pas
retrouver le mur dans la zone net et par
conséquent d'avoir ce fameux fou donc on
récapitule c pas compliqué quand
tueur et font éloigné égale bocquet
alors concrètement comment on s'y prend
un bain avec un reflex c'est le plus
facile
il suffira de rentrer dans les réglages
manuels de l'appareil et de régler
l'ouverture la plus grande possible
c'est à dire le chiffre le plus petit
possible est la même avec un fond
relativement près ce qui est le cas ici
avec doit être un mètre maximum
il y aura pas de souci on aura ce fameux
flou d'arrière plan easy quoi pour des
capteurs plus petits comme ceux des
smartphones c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué déjà sur la plupart des
smartphones l'ouverture et fixe donc on
ne pourra pas la règle et le capteur
forcément est tout petit ce qui fait
qu'il laissera rentrée très peu de
lumière d'où le fait qu'ils aient
quasiment jamais de flou sur vos photos
au smart phone
mais pour pallier à cela il suffira
d'appliquer les règles dont on vient de
parler tout en gardant en tête que la
zone de netteté sera forcément plus
grande puisque le capteur est plus petit
il faudra donc placé son sujet proche de
l'objectif est bien sûr de bien faire la
mise au point sur le sujet et enfin de
s'assurer que l'arrière plan est
suffisamment éloignée et bim magie
bocquet c'est donc surtout vous qui
allez devoir vous adapter à
l'environnement et vous placer
correctement par rapport aux sujets pour
être sûr d'avoir un fonds qui soit
suffisamment éloigné idéalement il
faudrait se retrouver dans un endroit
relativement spacieux autres techniques
possibles vous pouvez aussi tout
simplement déplacer votre sujet pour le
retrouver à l'endroit qui sera le plus
propice à la prise de la photo mais dans
tous les cas pas besoin d'un réflexe
pour obtenir cet effet même si c'est
forcément beaucoup plus confortable est
beaucoup plus facile de l'obtenir avec
un gros capteur enfin il faut savoir
qu'il existe des filtres logiciels qui
permettent de simuler cet effet bloqué
sur la plupart des appareils photos
maintenant et qui va consister à faire
en sorte que le capteur identifie le
sujet et le logiciel va s'occuper de
flouter tout le reste ça marche plutôt
pas mal
à condition d'avoir beaucoup de lumière
donc en soirée on oublie il faut quand
même s'attendre à quelques petits loupés
sur des éléments assez fin et ça c'est
pas non plus ultra ultra au point mais
franchement rien ne vaut un bon
placement et une bonne composition
quitte à retoucher un petit peu sur
photoshop ou sur lightroom des éléments
pour rendre le flou un petit peu plus
loin puisque avec un capteur de
smartphones on va pas non plus faire un
flou de malades et personnellement
j'aurais tendance à vous recommander la
version non logiciel de la prise de
photos tout simplement parce que vous
obtiendrez quand même des photos de
meilleure qualité
et puis c'est quand même vachement plus
fun de se déplacer puis vraiment prendre
la photo de
dc de réfléchir un petit peu à la
composition de la photo qu'on va prendre
et voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu vous avez appris des choses
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à exploser le
petit bouton bleu qui se trouve en
dessous de la vidéo et si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas pensez à vous abonner
ça fait plaisir et puis vous raterez
rien de la suite en attendant rester
curieux et moi je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]